welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars the Clone Wars season 7 episode to
a distant echo echo referring of course
to the return of echo and kind of refer
to anakin who perceives the obvious
nests of Padma's baby bump as a distant
echo like last week's season premiere
this was another more or less
shot-for-shot polish of the prerendered
story reels from a few years back and
hey no complaints for me about bringing
more humanity to the clone troopers and
more faith to their kills but now that
this storyline is part of a broader
final season they made a significant
change that redefines much of what we
can do about these characters timelines
heading into the events of Revenge of
the Sith and I'm gonna break it all down
spoilers if you haven't seen this
episode yet ok the episode opens with a
fortune cookie quote the search for
truth begins with belief now in the
original story real it was not one with
superior weapons but with superior
strategy but that's some heartless BS
you'd hear during like a game of Risk
this new quote conveys Rex's frame of
mind his belief that echo is still alive
despite how crazy it sounds guy it's his
journey to the truth and my journalism
degree requires me to inform you that no
fact finding truth mission should ever
ever begin with a prior belief that
shapes your investigation that's called
confirmation bias in its ruining this
country
and I would argue it's the secret darker
double meaning to this fortune cookie
that spells doom for Rex and other good
guys as their belief in this cause in a
war against the separatists lines them
to the real conspiracy we're just
getting started here baby okay Rex
Anakin Hunter debate the merits of the
echo rescue mission which probably bears
into a new scene not in the story real
first we have that thing to do hey what
thing you know well we don't have time
for that so
yes we do kissing and again his erect
stand guard as he face times of Padme in
the barracks this hole in axis arc is
set before the Battle of course sont in
the four-day events of Revenge of the
Sith and it wasn't until right after the
Battle of course not that Padme reveals
to Anakin that she's pregnant and he was
shocked yet here she is plainly prego
obvious baby bump she even cups a bump
like she's cut the promo for jittery
Springer yeah got a baby and this one's
yours Oh Anakin missed it well maybe
he's so into her face that he doesn't
look down or he's only seen Padme from
the front angle not from the side and
the holo projection throws off depth
perception or you know the animators
gonna the difference between a
first-trimester bump and a second
trimester bump in there making this show
for viewers who haven't been out of one
of these bumps for that long I just
think they wanted to use this moment to
remind us how close these events are to
Anakin and Padme relationships fateful
end on mooster park notice Padme is even
wearing a similar outfit that she'll
wear on Mustafar this is all designed to
squeeze our hearts with dramatic irony
as these two express their love for each
other we get these visual reminders of
the moment they stop loving each other
poster behind Padme shows our beche
words translate into space battles also
known as Star Wars and they depict abt
lby wings Starfighter which is a
predecessor to the white wings that the
rebels would use a generation later but
the big confirmation here comes from
obi-wan
I hope you at least told Padme I said
hello
kidding so yeah the novelization for
Revenge of the Sith
and past episodes of Clone Wars have
hinted that obi-wan suspected something
was going on between Anakin and Padme
but this is the most it's ever been
spelled out like this he knows and this
recontextualizes the reveal of Anakin
Padme is up there to be more of a just
poorly kept secret that a lot of people
know about anything about it it makes
obi-wan a smarter character it also
makes him a true friend to Anakin maybe
it's because the Clone Wars revealed
that obi-wan had a past romantic
relationship with Satine so like he kind
of gets it buddy anyway this new Padme
scene comes at a cost of a moment that
was removed from the story reel Anakin
finding the bad batches pinup knows art
of a sexy Padme on their ship hey what's
would the knows art that's a girl the
Naboo senator we check her out on the
Hollis gasps yeah she can negotiate with
me anytime let's get aboard that is not
staying there yeah I was a bit bummed to
see this go like it definitely could
have stayed in even with the new Padme
scene it's not really that dirty but I
guess it is kind of weird like are there
seriously no other babes in this galaxy
if it is trooper struggle then an
anti-war politician but no worries
though the Padme pinup remains canon the
animators snuck it into the ex clone
troopers 18 te in Star Wars rebels if
you look closely enroute to Sky coal
miner wrecker shoulder presses a donk
joy dwell eating a nuna leg new nazar
the swamp turkeys of Naboo known for
their tasty tasty deep-fried legs on a
surface they run into poll texts in
their flying reptiles that Kira Dax but
tech manages to translate with a group
and get their help to rescue their
friend from Pirkle where he's held by
the separatist at whet Tambor during the
hike wrecker reveals his fear of heights
hope nobody's scared of heights
well I'll know scatter nothing I just
when I'm up real high I got a problem
with gravity only anakin had listened to
record you would know the most dangerous
weapon is the high ground the Droid to
down the tower is super fun to watch
first arrive a few of the droids are
knocked out of a tower they scream
because yes they have souls but then
there's some real smooth action as
hunter knifes one droid and then we
follow the knife as he stabs another one
he back flips sweeps a leg should spew
then he grabs one by the neck and it's
shot by crosshairs who now gets the
focus slides in shoots a couple others
and then he hands off the focus to
Anakin who finishes off the last of them
the episode ends with the discovery of
Ecco still alive of course but hooked up
to wires harvesting his brain for
information notice how his eyelids
flutter and his pupils dart from side to
side like a machine being scanned I have
to get to the show to escape to sit atop
Heco's mind is returning to the exact
moment he appeared to die in season 3
when his ship exploded at the Citadel
despite echos rescue the ultimate truth
that rick's and the others fail to grasp
is that they are all in a way wired up
to a nefarious technology without their
knowledge
Echo's hooked up to these separatist
cybernetics and drives but all of the
clones are hooked up to the control
chips that will override all their human
instincts as order 66 will go out soon a
reminder that you can join this
conversation on discord after each
episode comes out more of our unfiltered
thoughts and theories by becoming a
patron today at patreon.com slash new
rock stars and a rider that if you want
us to continue these weekly Clone Wars
Episode breakdowns we really really need
more people to watch them otherwise we
can't really afford to spend time on
them each week like we might have to
condense episodes and do a bunch of them
at once just giving you a heads up but
you can help us do this every week by
liking this video and sharing it around
with everyone you know and commenting
down below with your favorite moment
from the episode of course subscribe did
new rock stars for breakdowns of
everything you love follow me I da vas
followed new rock stars social media
thanks for watching bye
[Music]